[Music]
surprise delivery news
mmm submitted by Canadian homies or sub
poutine I mean poutine in my routine a
couple unexpectedly received 65 pounds
of marijuana in their Amazon order
that's amazing
65 pounds someone do the math 65 times 3
it's like a hundred and ninety five
thousand dollars two hundred just a two
hundred two hundred sixty five times
three three hundred three thousand now
as some zeros because it's 3,000
thousand equals one hundred ninety five
thousand so I was right
human calculator 200,000 or 300,000
dollars what two hundred thousand
dollars when I was selling me a pound
went for about three grand for the
high-grade [ __ ] I don't know how much is
it it is right now do you think it's
more or less is now it's more little I
don't know inflation I know I don't know
that it could be less because now it's
the demands marked up Zach still 20
bucks no no no is an eight sixty
something I don't know [ __ ] is legal we
expensive dude remember next 2000
[ __ ] or our shrimp daddy yeah right
next door
we're like oh it smells like weed right
so we have a little place out in a this
food hall called Smorgasburg and then
one of the vendors there pulled out a
[ __ ] and pound a weed
it's a pound fits a ziplock bag you know
the massive size one and in freezer one
I just gather ton of weed there and I
was like he's rolling up a joint but I
don't know if his if his booth is
selling weed or that's just his personal
I think that's his personal stash
because he's he's a chef so he what's
his name I don't is your white guy no
okay never mind
of the brown complexion oh okay
annie has one of those rastaman beanies
I don't know him a red green and yellow
B towards this we're gonna figure this
guy out let me stop you there just
saying he's a fantastic person because
he offered me some and I told him sir I
do not smoke and he was like well if you
ever want to let me know I was like
alright I see that ziploc bag I'll let
you know it's legal in California all
right that's what you can pull it out or
no I don't think so not in public
yeah that's like drinking I will see of
your home and you need to still have
identification cards I see yeah I don't
know the law stuff I don't know what all
I'm saying is as a kid I could have been
a deep [ __ ] but then today it's a
different world that's probably how
people felt like during the would you
call it Prohibition era when you know
those speakeasies yeah go in the back of
a [ __ ] sardine factory and you're
like what's the password bones
yeah balance all right and you open up
and then there's all the yeah it's all
jazzy and there's like a lady with a
[ __ ] long-ass cigarette and she's
singing you know there's one yeah yeah
it looks like dragn a door like some
what is it Al Capone kind of there's a
couple of speakeasies in wolfs downtown
in downtown and also located on this
couple from Florida they flowered though
they ordered for 27 gallon storage
containers and yeah with dirt they knew
something was wrong because immediately
when they picked up the box or like what
way heavier I started laughing for no
reason they didn't discover that it was
marijuana until they started like
unboxing it because I guess they
packaged it so well that it masks the
smell oh I would love for them to do a
YouTube unboxing and bestow upon how
just a lot it is insider ever was doing
this and [ __ ] this up is definitely
dead
yeah just to put that out there 200 G's
with the week you're dead dead man and
so whoever worked
Amazon and didn't show up to work for
about two weeks just know it was that
guy yeah and so when the couple
discovered it they immediately called
the police
oh my god dweeb 'he's [ __ ] nerds well
you wouldn't be scared for your own life
I think not what state is this Florida
and what were they trying to order
continuum containers where have you been
I know he's like checked out for like
the past two minutes but the only
information she gave let's say they came
to my house and they're like where's my
[ __ ] weed I was like you mean that
bag of grass I threw that [ __ ] away like
what
Oh God as you we're not gonna kill me
yeah they want to friendly they're gonna
see like three other honda elements in
the driveway and like this will spent it
why does this flapper they're not gonna
look at any [ __ ] they're gonna see a
Honda Element he definitely didn't spend
this I'd call the company and I'd be
like check it out there's we here Bhama
sell it I'll give you 10% bye
why would you have the columns it's good
business practices Amazon no the company
but it was Amazon that Center yeah
Amazon is like a delivery there's like
businesses on Amazon yeah so you just
got to go to the user and say excuse me
you are probably trying to deliver this
to someone else but I actually got the
weed and I'm gonna sell it but why not
saying nothing and you keep a hundred
percent of there that's unethical if you
sell it and they like what you do you
really got yourself a a continuous
supply just saying I don't condone drug
dealing or anything like that I'm just
saying you want a Gus fring on your side
you don't want him to [ __ ] kill you
because you did something short-sighted
I'm thinking like Empire wise right you
get your connect you start dealing you
prove yourself in this world there's a
bright future for you then you gotta
shave your head gotta burn your
fingertips
all I'm saying is if you sell it it's
short-sighted cuz you're gonna die but
then you can get more and keep selling
it I don't condone drug dealing
doing I just don't like this scenario
for me because I would rather have me
open up a container and it's already
muddy I don't want to open it and then
have to do but that is money but no it's
not because you have to convert it and I
don't know how to drug deal you have
your friend right there I do he lives a
little too crazy for me and I feel like
it's gonna go a lot worse and it's gonna
be a whole drug ring and I want out and
that he's gonna slap me gangster kid
under his bed I know I'm like hey Joe I
got a lot of weed he goes got you all
right I'm waiting for this right now so
the authorities were able to trace it
all the way to Massachusetts to Amazon
warehouse of deals a UPS facility in
Massachusetts but they're still there
going back and forth with Amazon they're
trying to figure out who actually sent
it and so the couple the only thing they
got out of it was a $150 gift card as I
kind of worth it the woman is saying
that she doesn't feel that it's enough
she wants an apology and an explanation
all there are those types of people how
old are they by the way I don't know and
what color are they
just to say if they are of the uncle
that perhaps it might make a little
sense while they're asking for more
apologies well they're staying anonymous
because they fear for their safety their
actions kind of tell me what type of
behavior that is they didn't say in
their home for a few weeks
oh that makes that's pretty smart though
very smart they watch enough TV shows to
get some street knowledge so for several
days they stayed away from their homes
because for sure because I'm a comedian
I would put that in my stand who said
immediately and start telling the world
yeah and I would have been dead I don't
think I'm a comedian then I think I'm a
businessman yeah I like your story when
you were you're like ethically that's
wrong like you have to cut them a deal
but it's not ethically to just but for
him it's ethical to keep it and then
still sell it opposed to just giving it
back oh sure
well cuz I'm just trying to say
obviously their workers are incompetent
and they need new people to help them
out because they're not doing it right
go play go play if someone delivered
three cars to your house
brand-spanking-new and your life whoa I
didn't order this but thanks for the
Lamborghinis let me call the dealership
that it came from hey your guys [ __ ]
up but don't worry
I'll take care of it thanks due to
either do any work
BAM found myself a job you really have a
job good but I'm always looking if it's
[Laughter]
never too high or too low to accept the
job I like the perks and the benefits
that come along with being like a top
drug dealer with what are they what I
seen from TV you can awesome
you could backhand people and then
nobody does anything but everyone's
always trying to kill you but not your
friends well arrest you
especially yours as much as your friend
your friends want to take over yeah but
that's the TVs though in reality I know
people that's been in it for a very very
long time and no one's trying to kill
them or anything yes I just want to walk
in a room a people be nervous but
they're not like that in order to get
that kind of power you need to kill a
lot of people and you're not a killer
but that's like me though it's just how
I think of things is I want stuff
without the work though this is my
fantasy don't mean it's gonna happen
sorry
thank you I always say crime does pay I
don't know there's a reason why crime
pays is because it's illegal and no one
wants to do it that's why a pace this is
that overly saturated market know
everything Drugs sell themselves crime
there's no overhead you just take that's
why it pays but it doesn't last long I
don't know I guess scared that's why I
don't do it anymore it's scary how long
did you do it for probably from 14 to my
early 20s even while I was in college -
oh like oh crap I got bills to pay
better sell some ecstasy
boom bill came in goddamn AT&T through
the salsa mess oh and I always wondered
how did drug dealers even find their
clients you just talk to people I think
when you're in that world everyone wants
something out all the time so it's
really easy to get yourself plugged in
once you build the clientele for a very
long time and you go partying a lot
everyone in your world is on something I
just sold trades man oh my god you're so
dumb what you would get caught right
away
what the huh you know you're gumming
Clemson but you'll probably be good
you're clumsy David but you are very
social and social people go a long way
and they make people a lot wait so if
you're like the kingpin like the drug
lord whatever
why is your day today based on dropping
my self-esteem like what is going on
that's what we do that's always what the
[ __ ] first of all this is a fantasy of
mine who cares ah and to answer your
question no I won't trust them with the
drugs I'll have them send me clientele
and I'll give them a commission see yeah
you're smart you're gonna make it I'm
not gonna let them keep in your the
inventory in his house goddamn I called
9-1-1 and I forgot we're still going
weed here I understand that this person
was a cop but he was really nice he said
that if I brought him over that he was
gonna be super cool at best cool so
there's a bunch of [ __ ] cop locals
outside they all want to come in we're
good
we got to make a movie about this it'd
be fantastic hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode did you love
it I know you did but guess what you can
also follow us on our personal social
media accounts with the links in the
description box below so go follow all
of us now to watch more videos check
them out up there
you